diez meses después del caso que reabrió
la herida racial en estados unidos la
muerte del afroamericano church floyd el
ex policía acusado por su asesinato
directo wind se sentó en el banquillo de
los acusados el juicio se centra en
esclarecer la causa de la muerte de
floyd la acusación usó el vídeo del
fallecimiento de la víctima más de nueve
minutos en los que se puede ver al ex
policía con la rodilla en el cuello de
floyd mientras él clamaba que no podía
respirar un rato más mantener sus
cualidades secas cuando esto pues guay
ustedes aprenderán que en los últimos
nueve minutos y 29 segundos de vida del
señor floyd en ese periodo de tiempo se
puede ver como su muerte encaja con la
de alguien que muere por falta de
oxígeno podemos señalar la evidencia en
el vídeo lo podrán ver ustedes mismos
también verán evidencias de lo que no
fue no fue por ejemplo un paro cardiaco
fatal no fue por ejemplo un ataque al
corazón pero howard
así contestó la acusación al abogado de
la defensa que sostuvo que floyd tuvo un
paro cardíaco provocado por el abuso de
medicamentos y una dolencia cardíaca y
pidió aplicar el sentido común en el
juicio de chauvín
el sentido común nos dice que siempre
hay dos lados en una historia y el
sentido común nos dice que tenemos que
examinar la totalidad de las
circunstancias que determinan el
significado de las pruebas y cómo se
pueden aplicar a las cuestiones de la
razonabilidad de las acciones y
reacciones
pero algunos de los primeros testigos
que empezaron a dar testimonio también
constataron el uso excesivo de fuerza
por parte de la ex policía
y cuanto más tiempo pasaba con la
rodilla en el cuello más se podía ver
como floyd se iba desvaneciendo
fairway la muerte de floyd desencadenó
las mayores protestas por la igualdad
racial de eeuu en las últimas décadas y
la sentencia del caso marcará un antes y
un después para la comunidad
afroamericana